c'est tellement agréable d'avoir l'
opportunité de jouer quelqu'un qui peut rendre les
jeunes filles un peu plus confiantes un
peu plus dures à
cuire
Je ne pouvais rien faire de ce que je
voulais faire
[Musique]
eh bien, je veux dire que West End est ce que j'étais, c'est
là où j'ai grandi, je suis allé à
l'école d'art dramatique, donc c'était toujours
le rêve du Théâtre National
et et  tout ce qui est venu avec
cette
[Musique] qui a du mal à
parler 'pris très au sérieux
même si elle a des dragons pour
compagnie, elle est passée de cette jeune
enfant naïve à une véritable reine guerrière,
les réalités d'être vraiment une
reine et d'être un leader sont plus difficiles que
jamais alors elle aurait même
imaginé qu'elle est juste devenue de plus
en plus forte, donc pour une raison quelconque, cela a
eu un impact et cela ne se produit pas
tout le temps,
j'ai toujours été payé le même montant
que mes co-stars masculines, j'étais mon premier  travail
et je n'ai pas été victime de discrimination
parce que j'étais une femme dans mon salaire
[Musique]
les choses positives vraiment productives
qui peuvent arriver ensuite, c'est qu'il y a
plus d'obligations contractuelles en ce qui
concerne l'égalité sur le lieu de travail
[Musique]
J'avais l'impression que c'était un film  où nous pouvons
faire quelque chose de nouveau dans cette franchise qui
est tellement aimée
[Musique]
pour jouer une femme forte Je suis comme si je vais
vous dire ce que ça fait de jouer une
femme la fin c'est ça prendre le fort
ajouter trouver un autre adjectif  [ __ ] si
ce n'est pas fort qu'est-ce que tu me dis
qu'il y a une autre option il y a
comme une option faible tu penses qu'un rôle principal dans un
film va déjà être assez faible
avec une femme forte s'il te plait soyons juste
des femmes